Well guys, listen, do you feel the chill in the air? Do you feel the holiday spirit? I do. I feel the crackling of the fire. Oh, it's so nice, huh? Yeah. It's chilly outside. Nothing says a holiday.
It's like, oh, wait a second. We're not doing an ad. What are you doing? Like, yeah. This is just for smartness. Never go to the post office again. I think we're just doing a nice little holiday lead-in for this week's smartness.
Da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da. Oh my God. Smart, wise, smart, wise. Jason, you look beautiful today. You look really smiley and you're wearing a nice colored shirt that must mean that you're going to the office. Is that is that yeah Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I got a bunch of work to do today. Yeah, the office you do. Yeah, where you got like a driver off the tee No, I don't take a drive. I just self-drive. I don't drive myself to work Your car you don't have a self-driving car. Here's the thing last night was really fun
We all hung out. Yeah, we did and will was dabbing like crazy with the dab moves and then Jason Google's Google's dab because you didn't quite get it. No, hang on. Yeah, don't forget Jason held us one up and said hey Siri What does dab mean? Well, I want to know is it an acronym is it you know answered my phone just answered it was so And then what came up? one's father and I was that oh, she thought I said dad and then I said dab and And
Nothing, she didn't even she ignored me. No, and had you not in second and you've never seen someone dab before no I've seen the dab, but I want to know what you tell me. Yeah, I don't know. Don't get on my face about it I don't know what it is History of the dab or maybe Tracy knows Tracy might well Tracy knows she lives in Wisconsin She would know what that means dab capital of the world and then Jay and then Jay went on a little like side side thing where he was like Should I wear overalls? Do you want to know why overalls aren't aren't popular anymore? Yeah, I wore them a lot when I was 12 13 14 15 I mean, I thought they were that was fashion back then and now like there's you know
Like the Beastie boys have like the boiler suits, you know those little onesies or like like prison prison onesies I'd like to wear that like to just zip into something and just get out the door because it's easy. Yeah But what do you so what are you waiting for just bring them back? You'll be the one to bring I don't have that kind of I don't have that kind of style status where I can just you know Make something happen Jason's nervous that he'd be judged if I'm being if we can be honest He wouldn't want to be judged in that way so much that I don't I just don't want to be distracted by people yelling at me saying Hey loser get off the street, you know He's gonna you don't have to wear overalls here that attention to what you're doing
Yeah, I could give two fucks what you're doing. Listen. Let me say this. Yeah, I suggested That I want to go back to doing wearing overalls with no shirt sort of Dexys midnight runner style. I can't do that I don't why and then I and then just dance around on a street corner. Yeah Come on Okay Will's will's got new new earphones on Whatever they're called. What's uh, did you go little monitor? Oh, yeah, you don't have your big things on my little monitors I'm just trying for those. What do you think?
I bet you didn't I can't I can't confirm or deny anything right now But it looks like they might be molded for your ears because your professional voice over look at that What do you think about them? They're pretty good Yeah, they're pretty good and they keep they keep the the things away from your hair Well, here's the thing if you really want to know so the can so cans what you guys are wearing it what I usually use and have worn for Years and Everybody does it's very traditional like this. Yeah, as you know You wear them they're fine to wear for a little while if you're recording if I'm doing some spots for GMC, which is a superior vehicle
Especially the new GMC sear AT4x. Okay, GMC sear Wait, wait, what's the new what's the new catch phrase you've got it's sophisticated, but strong something like that. Well, it's about It's a big speaking of sophisticated and strong. Let's get to our guest because he's waiting Wow He's waiting. Don't cut off will with his great story about the the progression of they get hot is my point That's enough. We got it. Sean. Let's hear the guest Okay, okay guys, I'm super excited By the way, you like bring up a subject and I agree with it and then you you're like, why are you talking about that stupid thing? You fall into our humiliated me the other day without about
Anyway, sorry, here we go this person today one more time He's an he's an amazing human being an incredible actor one of the best actors of our lifetime truly Everybody loves this guy. I've had the immense pleasure of working in many times over the years He's won an Emmy. He's been nominated for three Academy Awards, and he doesn't know it, but I watch him Every single night on reruns of Cheers. It's Woody Harrelson. Woody. Hello. Oh How did you enjoy waiting that long I really enjoyed it. I didn't even want to come on I was like I was trying to keep myself from laughing, but I was laughing. He took a quick nap How did Sean how did Sean beat me and will to getting you on this show? I know we work together
Back in the day because we mean when you're tight, you know, you are you are surprisingly tight with a lot of folks Sean I know I think I know is everybody what did you Woody? What did you and Sean work on together? We worked on Cheers where I was at up Well, I'm great. I'm sorry. I'm willing great. We're gonna willing grace and then we did that live sitcom together where he played Archie Bunker and I played the neighbor. Oh, no way. Okay. Well, why don't we let him answer that? I asked what is the guest? Well, just in case you didn't remember Well, also also Woody I was at a party at your house years and years ago where I made out with Alicia Silverstone When she she she's one of the sweetest people I was she knew I was gay
It was like no big deal, but you're just being silly Wait, what? Yeah, hang on. Yeah, sorry what it would be you in one second Sean walk me through walk me through with that what that negotiation was like. Hey, Elise. Oh, we were children We were children. How old is that? Like early 20s. Okay, and she you said to her not that she needed to hear it that you are gay But that you forgotten what it's like to kiss a girl's mouth and and and you asked her You asked her, would you like to kiss a gay man's mouth? Let's get let's We were being silly we were
Drinking we were young we were drinking and it was Woody Harrelson's house and it was fun. That was a party Wow, what do you what do we find you of today? You look like you're in a beach community. No, I'm in a Winnipeg. It's a beautiful day in Winnipeg. Here comes the Canadian wait a second Wait a second way to say woody my whole family both sides of my family are from Winnipeg. Really? Yeah, okay Is there anyone you want me to look up? Yeah. Yes Quick, what are their names? Well, what do you ask them what their names are? Yeah, what are their names? Yeah, he has no idea. Well, that's not true. I got my cousin Sally and my cousin Joanie and And uh, you're making all this up and talking great aunt. No, no, no go visit my great aunt. Uh, you know
Any in any am no, we're not doing anti and Wizard of Oz polls here Um, what are you doing at Winnipeg? Um, I'm doing this movie called champions. Uh, bobby fairleys directing. Oh great. Yeah Now is it uh, is it one of his, uh Uh newer films that are more dramatic uh in tone or is are we back to uh semen in the hair? That was the original time it didn't clear someone had it already so they went with something about mary. Um, this is a comedy This is a comedy. Oh good. Yeah
Are you all done with um with uh, Justin Thoreau? Yeah. Yeah, we finished that six months. We did that Good lord. Yeah, that was crazy because of covid stuff. Is that why it took so long or was it a was it a bunch of episodes? Well, there was a couple of uh shutdowns actually Yeah, was that due to Thoreau's lack of sleeves? Did that enter into it? Was that part of the Yeah, why they had to shut it down the sleeve local come over and shut you down Uh, listen or this we're talking about a watergate. Uh, a watergate, uh show that woody did with Justin Uh for hpo. I think it should be pretty funny. Yeah, white house plumbers. Yeah, I'm very looking for that Oh, it's gonna be great. I I gotta say Justin really knocked it out of the park and uh, must have been a pretty small park
Dog park Wait, wait, wait, wait, woody. Let me ask you this. I've always wanted to know this about uh, first of all, great to see you man I'm so happy you're here I wanted to get you on this thing so bad, too. And then um, so you started your first big thing was cheers obviously you came on after coach I forget the actor's name. He was really terrific. Yeah, Nicholas calisanto
Yeah, Nicholas calisanto, but you came in and it was like big shoes to fill and you came in woody man And you were shot out of a cannon episode. It felt like you had been on the show forever drilled it. You were great I loved you on the show. I mean, there's so many I still to this day do Kelly Kelly Kelly Kelly ke l l y I mean, I fucking love it. How did Cheers come about how did it come into your orbit? How did you audition for what? Yeah What what was that experience like started to go way back? But we have to go back to and just to tag on to that woody before you answer that
I I didn't know this until I was researching some of the stuff that you're from Hanover So will's question about how did it start and how did you get it and also the Hanover woody? Obviously, they took your name and they took your hometown too. Was that your idea their idea? Well, the character was already called woody boy But and the character was from indiana. I'm not from there, but I went to college at Hanover So I did ask him to use that but uh, you know to answer your question. I was uh I got a little break from this show. I was doing or I was an understudy in this
Neil Simon Biloxi blues and So I got a little break to go do a movie with Goldie Hawn and and then as I was wrapping up They fired the two guys. I was understudying. So I was going to get to go on stage, which is that was my dream. I was 23 I was 23. Anyway, this buddy of mine Leo Jeter in LA. I run into him and you know, my agent hadn't said anything But he says, you know, there's this part on the show called cheers that you should look into, you know Wow, I was like, well, he says the guy's from indiana. His name's woody That's so crazy. And had you seen the show before wait wait, no way And the agent commissioned 10% for how many years? Yeah. Yeah for doing, uh
Yeah, but yeah, no, but anyway, so I was at the time. I was really into this idea I'll just do theater. I will not be You know doing television, but then I watched it and I was like, oh man, this is uh pretty good Yeah, yeah, and was it was it a hit? I knew it took a while to become a hit But was it a hit when you joined? Well, it had been on for three years. It was a hit But it did it then it kept going, you know kept Yeah, when you did the thing the the archibunker thing, was it nice to get back into that
Into that rhythm into that schedule again into that, uh, the sitcom stuff and with jimmy burrows and all that Did it bring back a bunch of memories? Isn't that fun? Yeah. Yeah, that was really cool I I didn't get into work with jimmy, you know, shon. I mean fuck. Yeah, that was awesome. Uh, but I was a little scared, you know, just Archibunker, you know, oh you were so great. You were so great. Oh, thanks. You were so good. Yeah, perfect You're never bad. You're never bad and you know, like I think I think I think the public and maybe the industry probably thought They've had you pegged and pigeonholed probably five or six times and and inevitably your next job is like Wait, he's in what and he's playing what character and then you watch it and you're like Jesus I never knew woody had that side. I mean, there's just nothing you can't do
It truly and I remember seeing you to Jason's point you pop up here and there in your career And then when I saw you natural born killers, I was like, wait, that's woody harrelson from cheers and natural born killer And that was one of the best performances I'd ever seen you just it was incredible everything like Jason just said everything you do is It's amazing. I mean keep going me out of the furnace. It's just like crazy good Just on and on and on so tell me about natural born killers and what it was like working with Oliver stone because I'm sure you have some insane moments or stories Oh, there were some insane moments for sure, but uh, no, I I liked working with him. He can be a little uh You guys ever hung out with him? You must have never you know, he tries to stir shit up all the time really
But like I'll give you an example like one time There's this scene where there's like there's all these windows outside of this pharmacy that are these cops have me trapped Inside this pharmacy and they're gonna so all the windows get blown out from them shooting at me in the pharmacy and I'm supposed to run and do whatever and uh, so there's huge giant windows Uh, and and it's all three of these mega windows getting blown out and Oliver comes to me just before the take and goes uh Uh, uh, this is an hour and a half reset. Don't fuck it up rolling
Thanks for the pet dog Oh, jeez, but you nailed it nailed it You know what I mean about that that whole sort of that that discipline toggle switch I think everyone has got a hit, you know, when you're when you're when you're doing stuff Um, you you come across as someone who just kind of you know, it's real casual about a lot of things in life You don't get hung up on a lot of stressful stuff But there's got to be a side of you that knows how to flick that switch and just be an assassin when you need to whether it be Just discipline on preparing for work or at the moment
hitting the switch and delivering Is there a side to you that is a side that you you don't really show a lot of us But is sort of your your your private sort of secret weapon where you can really get small and uh an execute No, no, it's all casual No Jason you what you need to know Jason is that guys like Woody and me it just comes to us organically It's we just fucking we don't think about it. We don't think we don't we're not premeditated, dude Like you Woody and I are just operating on a different plane. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Well, by the way
I've I've seen you in quite a number of things and And then I'm like watching the morning show and then you pop up in the morning show He's got a high overhead. You're just what you're doing everything. You got a lot of overhead I'm just trying to I'm just trying to make people question what they think about me You know what I mean? Like I just want to keep him guessing Woody I'm doing it on a smaller scale than you've been doing and now I'm ready to take it to the next level Well, we're guessing and we will be right back And now back to the show Woody and I have uh that I can barely remember so I know Woody
You probably can't remember because you're are you are you are you older than I am? I'm 52. How old are you? Yes, I'm older than you dude. Remember when I met you you were like 17 Right, we've got some history. So yeah, Woody and I think did we first meet doing the uh doing the car race? Well, no, I I think I met you before that, you know, because I was so overhanging out With Mike and Paramount and yeah, I might have met you before that But that's where we really, you know started to get to know each other was in that Yeah, so Justina and I do this car race this celebrity car race Toyota Grand Prix along beach that Woody was in as well and um How'd you do it?
Uh, I did I did well. I think I won that one. You won that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, so we were training And they didn't obviously they didn't test for cocaine back then that it was So we were so we're training we're training at uh Well willow springs and woody and I are driving the same color car and woody woody drops a couple of wheels over into the dirt On a real high speed turn so he gets across the track and does like 14 cart wheels and his cars ripped apart like the whole back end whole back half was ripped off And it's upside down and it's resting in the in the in the oh my god On the side of the track and all of us cars come driving by it because you know, he's ahead of us
And he's upside down the smoke everywhere and you can see him hanging upside down In his driver's chair hanging from his five point harness Because the whole back half of the car had been ripped off and he's in the same color cars And justine thinks it's me. So she pulls over her car. She's all she's freaked out She's screaming and crying and then I come driving up. I'm like, oh my god. Who is that? Is that woody? She's like, oh my god, you're alive. Oh my god. It's woody So should we all go and try to help them and get out and all that stuff that was that yeah, that was a real Uh, that was a scary moment and I remember you only broke a little a little bone in your hand. Is that right?
Yeah, I broke two bones in my hand And uh, a couple of teeth got uh, no cracked But yeah, pretty lucky because uh, everybody Saw it said they thought it was a fatality because I did I from well, you know, it's one of those were I looked at my Uh, spedometer, which you should I shouldn't have done I remember turn nine there Jason. Yeah, it's flat out. Yeah, you could go flat out on turn nine And I looked down at my speedometer and said 105 And then my god when I look back up
I'd just gone think just a little bit off the track and then of course I over compensated which caused the car to skid for a moment and then whoosh just launched and um But 40 feet before landing because the guys went and looked at the headlights tail lights and everything did six and a half windows Uh after that and uh, yeah, god, I did the whole white light thing. Really? It was incredible and and and did that did that keep you from racing it? No, he didn't know that was just training We went on and did the race like a few weeks later
And then he crashed in the race, of course Well, do you still race Woody? It's all the coke No, I know right that I got over it after that. Yeah, my god I was shortly behind you. Oh, and then Woody and I picked up our dangerous escapades That probably what was it a year later in New York City? We decided we were hanging out late late late at night walking around the streets of the couple of buddies of mine All banged up and you know all those piles of trash all the trash bags that get put out on the sidewalk They just they're like create these big large lumps of trash bags like 20 of them
I thought it'd be fun to do like a Diving contest into these trash bags like a flip contest. Do you remember that Woody? Am I remember this correctly? We do like flips and cartwheels into it and land into the bags Yeah, yeah, you were you were wild, dude. You were actually I lost my privileges Shortly after that, but you got it together, but we made it. We made it. We're still making a living. Yeah, we're still good for us okay so
Woody It seems to me like you're one of those guys who Just doesn't stop working. I mean you're by the way, you're in uh, you're in solo, which is one of my favorite movies ever the Star Wars movie solo. Thank you. Um, you seem to you seem to constantly work never ever stop Do you love that you wish like oh god? I need a break It doesn't seem like you ever take a break because you still love it Well, you know, that's a good question because like I haven't been home since april imagine not being home since april Wow, and you would think that I love nothing more than to work
But honestly, I'm uh, I'm a very lazy hippie who somehow just got himself in this predicament And once I get through this, you know, once I make it to christmas. I'm taking some time off for sure And then where's home nowadays? Is it Costa Rica? No, I I moved from Costa Rica. I live in Maui Okay, that's great. Yeah. All right. Oh, that's awesome Um, I do have I do have a question from from a listener a listener in new york city named justin t Oh, hello that you may or may not have worked with He I was chatting with him He has a question for you. Uh, you're this is this is literally I didn't know that we were taking questions from listeners
It's from a random listener named justin t. Oh my god. So, uh, He he wants to know you're well known for your love and abuse. This is his worst My You're well known for your love and abuse of marijuana and other mind-altering substances Has work ever gotten in the way of your drug problem? And wait and follow-up question has your drug problem ever suffered as a result of your work Thank you caller Uh, justin t. That's a very, uh, insightful question. Uh
As a matter of fact, uh, it does sometimes get in the way because like I'll I'll wake up I want to wake and bake. I'll be like, I can't wake me. I can't fucking wake and bake. Gotta wait till lunch. Yeah Thanks for asking that I can't believe that he had time to ask that write that question down Just because you know, he's usually just avoiding paparazzi. That's his number one Job like so the fact that he had the time to write that down. God bless Uh, no, but seriously, have you have what have you ever worked totally stoned like and it's like on cheers or anything Where you you're in a scene. You're like, I don't know where I am. Oh, yeah, I uh
I was doing cheers and you know, we've been doing it for a while. Uh, so I don't know several years and and uh Uh, then I was I well, I thought we were done and I went up and I was smoking a joint with George went And uh, I hear over the intercom. What do you come down for your monologue and scene c and I'm like, oh Oh And I go down And it's like First take disaster second take worse, you know, takes me 10 takes and jimmy's like, what do you everything? Yeah, everything's fine jimmy everything's fine. Yeah, let's just try it again
You know, so what would have been one simple, you know, it would just took like 10 fucking takes is a disaster So I learned that I can't you know all the things that you just take for granted just kind of go out the window I mean, you're probably uh will and jason. I'm sure uh have done cocaine while filming and you know, it just doesn't work Jason it's not fun. You spent I did it once and I spent my whole time trying to not look like I was all beaked up Yeah I remember we asked remember we asked seth rogan last year. We were like, man Do you ever shine you asked him like do you ever, you know, you ever gotten high before you work? And he was like, I've never not worked high
That's crazy. I know is that right? Yes. Yeah, he said that's what he said. I heard chris walken would would get high before doing shakespeare in the park Oh my god, it's how do you if you get lost how do you start improvising in iambic contaminant? Like how's that work? Wow I know that's crazy. How do you get that back? But I guess the old guys they used to all those old shakespeare actors those guys used to boost it up like over You know on the other side there in the uk those guys used to all get ahead Oh, yeah, but I feel like that might be different than weed like weed would for me
It would be tough to remember my lines. I'd get too distracted probably I know that it's more about just like Going home and powering down for me. What about a gummy jason? Could you do it on a gummy? I might be able to just because you know, it goes into the blood system a little bit slower It doesn't punch you in the neck like a big fat hit off a doobie or a bomb, you know Yeah, woody. I think the last time I saw you. This is this is a great Not not much of a name drop, but the last time I saw you was at your birthday at bono's place In the south of france. Is that true? Yeah, dude. I I was so psyched to see you
You know, I love arrested development. I fucking love that show Love it and um, shan's never seen it. Thank you. What if shon is not shon? You got to watch it. It's really good and uh, what's it called? It's a group called the rest of development. It's a hip hop band out of atlanta and That moment you had where you come in the window to break up with the you know, your teenage girlfriend is within and and then the next morning it cuts to you're sitting there eating your eggs And and and she says so what was it you wanted to talk to me about and you're like, uh, well
What is it? Uh, and then you get into that shit should the guy should the guy should $35 I do it all the time by the way and people have no idea what I'm doing and I'm like I have to then explain This is actually $3,500 suit Yeah What was confusing about that scene was that I come out and I'm wearing her I'm wearing her nightgown and she's wearing my shirt from the night before
So we realized as as we were rolling I was kind of I knew that mitch was going to get what I was trying to do so that I started to Downgrade how much her thing was worth and then I started to upgrade what she was wearing because she was wearing my shirt So it was like such a fucking like and then mitch was like I can't believe this is happening But it was so funny to me that I'm like should the guy and then and I started sort of Complimenting how much hers is worth anyway, so woody so we're at bono's place in this big birthday party for woody and his Wife's there and his daughter comes in surprises him and bunch of people are there. It's really beautiful night and and um woody's like oh man
And he and he started we start laughing about that scene He's like and he was doing the scene to me And then like dinner was served and bono comes over and he's like and he kept going guys dinner served and woody's What he's on the ground doing the scene and finally I think he got a little bit pissed and he was like And he was like hey woody well you guys can do it over there at the table. We're like, all right, man. Sorry We're doing scenes from a wrestling development bono It really to me it's it's one of the it's maybe the greatest comedic moment ever Intelligent
That's nice. I still watch it and just I tear up laughing. I love it And I know you were going through a hard time that day because you told me so it's amazing. You were able to do that Oh, well, what happened? I was having a that was one of the worst days of my life. That's true I did tell you that that night it was a very I was going through a lot of stuff personally and couldn't find the moose for your hair Because it was moose back then right Oh Um woody uh speaking of uh lines you quote and stuff like I said at the beginning When you popped on here that I'm obsessed with shares. I I've seen every episode so many times
And what you achieved we touched on this a little bit before you achieved with a lot of actors in tv Don't do which is kind of cultivate a massive gigantic film career afterwards What did that kind of happen to you? Did you seek it out? Like how well how did that transition happen for you? Well, I mean, I guess we're all seeking it out, right? Yeah, right, so but you know, it really was uh, I I got to do doc hollywood with mike Uh michael fox and then that did well Uh, and then it was lucky that I played basketball, you know, my agent told me later, you know All those times I was trying to get you and you were down playing hoops down in Santa Monica or whatever
You know Paid off because of white men can't jump and ron shelton who actually I call it. I guess it was bush war one at the time was going on and he had heard me You know protests it I said something like the war on terrorism is terrorism Which uh upset a lot of people and caused me to lose uh Uh, you know lucrative other things that were going on it didn't matter, but ron shelton very much liked it Was glad I did that scott weller scott weller's doppelganger ron shelton by the way Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah separate to birth. Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. Sorry
Scott was scott weller's a buddy of ours lives in the south bay. He's a handyman He's got a great handyman business opening great handyman. Listen if something's broken, you need to fix you You're in the south bay. Yeah, you're in the south bay red man hat beach and something breaks you call scott weller and his handyman business through home hardware Let me write that down. So scott weller if i'm in there's a number at the bottom of your screen south bay california All right, so there's ron shelton. He puts you in white men can't jump that that is hugely successful Yeah, huge and then on from there, right? Yeah, I mean it hasn't stopped That's great. Was it has has there been has there been a slow period that that was not by design?
Has it slowed down for you? There was After people versus larry flint Um, so brilliant things uh kind of Because that was disappointing to uh, sony Even though a lot of people maybe watched it after you know, but at the time they didn't and and also it was really Gloria steinham had gone on a Went from one place to another all over the country telling people not to see it. Uh, this is our pray op-ed which uh was devastating um and uh
Anyway, so people would tell me look i'd like to watch it, but uh, you know, my wife won't let me see it Yeah, so that that was a real uh, isn't that weird things kind of went down after that and that was also when I decided Uh, I'm gonna just stop working for a while. So I did for five years. I weren't you nominated for that Yeah, yeah, you were nominated for an oscar and things went down after that Wait, wait, wait, wait a second. Let me show you cut them up. So for five years. What are you five years? You basically? Yeah, from like around 97 to 02 Other than I did one thing, uh, which i'm glad I did uh Uh for ron Howard the ed tv, you know with oh, yeah, which is where I got to know matthew
That's great. Uh, and then I did one other little thing Other than that. Yeah. Hey, I didn't work. Oh, and I did theater I was like, I want to get in touch with my roots, you know So like from around 97 to 2002 Yeah, I I didn't do anything and probably, you know, the phone wasn't ringing off the wall or anything during that time Yeah, and then when I started when I came back to work again I was like, you know, I'm not expecting a tick or tape parade or anything, but I thought there'd be no There was nothing it was completely. I was completely forgotten and I was just
Trying desperately to get anything and anyway, it was a slow. What was the first big thing that restarted it? Well, I did this movie, um after the sunset of Pierce Brosnan and Salma Hayek, uh, Brett Ratner And uh, even though it didn't do that well, I think it started, you know, just kicking things off You know how it goes guys, you know, yeah, it's uh, it's up and down. Yeah Well, I'm sure but you know, it's great what he's I bet that people are like Love to take credit of going like that they rediscovered you like, yeah, you know, what are you?
Yeah, would he be really great like you haven't changed you've been great since you started And it's like everything else takes you know It's so funny perspective is fucking crazy because you do that people versus Larry flint and as Sean said you were awesome Obviously you were nominated. You were awesome. My recollection seeing that film in the theater was How great it was and how great you were and if you were to ask me like boy if you were to say like what? You know, uh, uh, you know, how's Woody Harrell? Oh, he's great man. Yeah, he just did that people versus Larry flint He was incredible. He was nominated. He's a great actor and he's so good and he's so diverse and he can do kind of anything And when the reality of your perspective is totally different, but it's so fucking crazy and it's so subjective, right?
I mean, that's bizarre. It's gig to gig still. Yeah, always. Yeah, always. It's crazy always. Um, Jason's about to take five years off He didn't know it. Yeah. Oh, no Yeah, yeah, I just talked to showbiz. They said you're taking five years And was that an alert that you got or? We'll be right back And now back to the show Let me switch for a second and two. I know that you've um You've got some uh, some beliefs and some passions in sort of like a lot of sort of our environmental stuff
And I do as well and and if you're like me sometimes you get a little bit frustrated with the slow pace of things How do you manage your your happiness or lack of based on the progression or lack of on sort of tackling some of these things that are Really kind of existential. We don't want to get into politics too much. We don't like to on this show that much But I'm just wondering if you got a tip for me. Is it about not watching the news or not reading the paper to see the slow pace of things Or is it the opposite? How do you manage your your frustration? Well, I mean, I I do feel like the The the world's kind of going to hell in a handbasket and uh, yeah, I feel like sometimes Uh, you know with the global warming and that you see the effect of it even here where it's unnaturally warm Although it's fucking freezing balls here. They for them. They're it's unnatural warm
and uh You know, you see it everywhere. You see the signs of it. It's not a mystery that the That the global warming is having a devastating impact and uh, all these predictions that were made, you know 30 years ago 40 years ago are coming true and then, you know People say well, you know Well, things are moving foot. Well, I I don't know. I mean, it seems like the big oil companies and all the giant freaking You know industries that have raped mother earth on a daily basis for
They forever. Yeah, it seems like they just keep doing business as usual and and I don't see Change is happening. Um, so how do you manage your frustration with that? I don't know. I it really I think about it every day. I I know I really I was gonna say Jason. I was gonna say one of the things and woody you can speak to this You know, I remember when we did semi pro 10 12 years ago with will ferrell And you had that your bus, which I think you still have that you use as your trailer And what do you have this bus that run that runs on?
vegetable oil biodiesel biodiesel He's got like a cork floor. It's got all this stuff. It's like renewable You've been doing it. You've been kind of walking the walk for a long time and it's like, yeah The first, you know, the thing that you can do is everybody could do it if everybody thought like that more It's it's about changing once again changing our perception and changing how we approach stuff, right? Yeah, I mean, I think it really has to do with how we How we feed ourselves, uh, you know How we feed ourselves
Planetarily, you know, what our fuel is and also what our personal fuel is. I think is also Incredibly important What would they say and I was watching the news the other day that that growing cows for for food is 2 thirds of the of the world's pollution Is that right or what it takes to to farm cows? Is that right? Or is it one third something like that? I think that it's a huge thing. Uh, the the methane generated from Cows and what is that? Like from their from their poop. Is that is that the methane? Yeah, I think it's from uh, just there
Really? Yeah, yeah, meanwhile throw it on your flowers and it's okay cow crap is killing our planet. Is that right? It's their farts. It's the farts Cow farts the farts You know farting there was a time when farting was really funny. Yeah, no now it's killing. That's killing us killing us Uh, what do you look what type of stuff are you eating nowadays? Are you full? Are you a full vegan? Oh, yeah. Well, I've been a vegan for uh, since 1990 January one but yeah
I I'm mostly raw. I try to eat mostly raw. You know, you gotta like a salad if you're eating mostly raw. So yeah, I love salad I just uh, you know, I want to eat as clean as possible. Uh, you know to compensate for my other Uh Issues pollutions. Uh-huh. Yeah Now how do you find it difficult to get raw clean food as you travel around the world? Is I mean, I imagine it's got to be a lot easier in the major cities But when you're gone location in different parts you have to bring food with you
Or you have like a a cook or something like that. Yeah, I have a chef here. Yeah, they miss Cole. She's great. Yeah Yeah, uh, but yeah, I know I know it's a little bit of a privileged lifestyle guys. I guess it is No, no, but I I mean, you have to apologize to us. Yeah, I know you're the privileged, of course Yeah, I don't know what now. Let me ask you this. Do you know when you do go city to city? How do you get your weed? Do you have connects in every city? That's what I need to know because it's legal everywhere, isn't it? Most places it's legal, you know Look, I mean, I used to carry it with me, which was a stupid move
but And then I realized at one point. Oh my god, it's everywhere You know, now is it is it legal up in Canada? Yeah, it's legal. Oh, there you go. So you got you just go down to the store You just pick up some milk and do that. Yeah, I remember when you had me you gave me a taste of your spirulina or something like that Yeah, that stuff's good thing. I'm just fucking threw up More than that, that's the analogy. It gives you nice nice energy. Yeah, it's good for you. It's really good for you. Mix it up with stuff Woody before I forget uh freak brothers. It's a new cartoon you're in with John Goodman, Tiffany Haddish What else is in it? Pete Davidson is in it. That's good. That's crazy. It looks great
You and John Goodman perfect. You I love that because you guys are both so soft. What cartoon is that? What's it on? It's called freak brothers. What is on to to be right fabulous furry freak brothers Uh, yeah, too. It's on to be to be Do I have to be Hey, can we get that as a as an audio bite uh guys rob just pegged that just remember that do I have to be That's their tagline. Do I need to go on hypochondria actor to figure out if I've got to be or no I want to get this on a clip so I can be like Fred on Howard Stern where I can just keep me clicking. Do I have to be How does one get to be oh my god, keep going
You're asking me Yeah, man, you're the spokesman. He doesn't know what he said to be with a question mark. I'm Just ask one of your assistants to download it for you. Yeah, man He says wait, what do you go back? I want to talk about Matthew McConaughey. I didn't know you guys were so close You guys are good buds, right? Yeah, yeah speaking of you and Matthew Are you are you aware of the of what you have done for this industry with what you guys did with true detective? Yeah, and in making the the limited series a cool. Yeah the television space for like when Two big shot film actors like you guys come on and like I would equate it to when Fincher did house of cards on Netflix
The combination of those two things. I think well, it's just expanded so much more So many more places for everyone to work Well, it made it feel okay and not like because there used to always be that thing of like it wasn't cool to do And then you guys came in film. I don't do tv on apologetically. You guys fucking kill it. God. I love that What are you and Matthew and that thing was so good. Oh, thank you guys. It's such a great job. Yeah Yeah, it was so fucking good. And then it's just like made it okay for everybody to do that. Like that was huge Did you love doing that project? Yeah Uh, I mean, you know, there were times I would
I would get kind of angry with uh, Matthew, you know, I had one of my best buddies So it felt weird, but he was in character in that fucking character Just made me want to fucking slap him. I was He's so good, you know, but he didn't stay in character and you know, not after work But while we were at work, you know, it wasn't like hey buddy, you know, none of that Uh, so that was a little but anyway, it turned out good. Yeah Did you have a sense while you were doing it? How good it was and what the style of it was or did Carrie Foucahnaga sort of not really was it was it not that
Clear you had to really watch a lot of play back to get a sense of it or could you tell while you were shooting it? Uh, I mean, I thought it was going to be good, but you know, it's rare You find a thing like hit the zeitgeist like that. That that's extreme. I mean you have it already, you know, you got ozark You got the uh rested development You know, you you're mr. Zeitgeist Jason, but for the rest of us, it's a very it's a very Great So, yeah, it was wild. I had no idea that it would be, you know, that kind of thing And I thought it did turn out really good. So good. Yeah, fantastic. You're so great now
So, um, what about, um, I want to know because these guys hate it hate this but I'm a huge huge huge star wars freak and when you were in solo, I was like, oh my god, that's so cool and uh, were you a fan of it before or were you just like I'd say what he's pretty close to art to today's new Harrison Ford. I would I would anoint him the new Harrison Ford Right, if you were gonna cast on solo today, I'd put what he had. That's a big thing to say. That's a big thing to say. Yeah Yeah, I'm sorry. Go ahead. Wow. Thank you. Do I have to be? It's from that guy that's where your compliment came from. No, I want to know I want to know if you were a fan of the star wars franchise over you
Kind of a fan and not just was like, oh, I could learn to like this or whatever No, I was kind of a fan You know, I wasn't like a mega fan because these fans out here of that the star wars stuff I mean, those guys are pretty serious. So I would be I don't think it's a fair to call myself That kind of fan, but I you know, I liked it, of course Wasn't there a director swap in the middle there and you had to redo a bunch of stuff with Ron Ron Howard. Yeah, that was a long long shoot. I'll bet It was it was like
Maybe nine nine ten months total by the time we were done Yeah, at least nine months retooling it. How did you like living in England that long? Yeah, and I'd been there on a project just before so I was in in london for a year Uh, which you know, I like london, but that was a year. What do you did that thing? Didn't didn't you do a live tv thing? Was that what you were doing? That's what I did before. Yeah, it was cool What was that deal? Yeah, it was uh, it's called uh lost in london. I wrote it and directed it and uh Uh, yeah, it was it went live in the theaters, which was cool. That had never happened. Oh, wow I remember that. Yeah, how did you like doing that? Was it more stress than it was worth or was it?
It's super exciting. Well, yeah, you know, it was like theater, but like on a you know on another scale with 500 extras and 500 crew and You know It was it was wild the stress nearly nearly killed me I got to say I I don't know when I've ever been that fucking stress All kinds of shit the sound wouldn't work. I gotta see that and the and the and the The the the we did a run through the night before the video goes out for 45 minutes the the feed I mean, it's like so this was basically a live movie that you were beaming into movie theaters. Yeah. Yeah
Wow, where did that idea come from that sounds like a Total like a like a like masochistic It was masochistic. Well, I I had already decided I wanted to do it in a one or you know, so it was a single camera and uh I'd already decided and then someone else mentioned a buddy of mine Tom cartesotus mentioned Hey, why don't you just beam it right into the theater while you what?
That's a crazy idea and then started finding out You know went to different people to see if it could be done and everybody was like, well, no, I it can't be done And then finally someone said yes So did that did that kill the the the desire to direct anything else after that? Or did you go on and direct other stuff? Well, I would like to direct something else But I don't want to do it in a one or or live. I'd rather have multiple tapes There's a million things I would have done different honestly But it turned out pretty good. Yeah, and Owen Wilson's in it and Willie Nelson. It's good. I'd love to see that
I know how cool is that? I think you can find it on to be or something. Jason. Do you have to be under it? Do I have to be? Oh my god, it's my favorite Woody we we've taken a lot of your time today I really appreciate you being here and I know you're stuck in Winnipeg working So please don't say stuck in Winnipeg to all our friends in Winnipeg. We love you. We especially my family Woody, I'm going to send you some people you got to go see Oh, I'm sure he's going to love that. Oh, great. Obligate him to a couple of at-home dinners Do they cook raw? I mean, come on, Will
Do they cook raw? They got to uncook it Well, I'd uh, sure love to see you in person when you're done up there in Canada And maybe while you're switching planes down here on your way to Maui, just let us know we'll meet you down at LAX I would love that. Woody, come to town and come to have to hang out with us, man. Come on, Woody I would love it. Do you guys ever hang out with each other or are you just always Last night, always. Just last night No, last night, every night and Wednesday night and Thursday every night. These are the only people we see live
Yeah, it fit right in. Come on. It fit right in. Come on in, man Yeah, well, this has really been a pleasure. I gotta say, you know, I hate doing interviews, but this was a fucking fun one Thank you so much guys for making it so fun. I can't remember one question. We asked you I know, but wow, I'm glad you did it. We find we love you, Woody. You're the best. Yeah, I love you pal Thanks, Will. Love you too, man. Sean, love you, brother Jason. What a pleasure. Love you pal And guys, uh, see you next time. See you at LAS. See you next time, Woody Okay, buddy. All right. Okay, pal. Bye, buddy. See you, pal I
Love Woody. Who doesn't he's the best. He's a great dude. I know It's terrible that he lives all the way out there in Maui. Why doesn't he uh, I didn't know he lived there If we pitch in and get let's pitch in and get him a small studio apartment in Los Angeles So he could spend more time in LA and more time with us Yeah, we'll get him a place like like in north Hollywood just like a nice little unassuming so it won't cost us 500 square feet Let's go. By the way, let's get wise. Let's go visit him in Maui Maui, what are we doing? That sounds smarter. That sounds better. It will go, uh I do feel like
We should be seeing more of him and we'll never do what we see him We see him on the uh, on the big screen on the tv and the big and to be don't forget. Oh my god. Do you Do I to be do you have to I would love to to be I know you it is not enough snow out there to By the way, this is turn into an ad for to be. I know lucky. What it what is it? But how would you pronounce? How do you pronounce that I am? Oh, that's quick. Let's get right to it Yeah, do you not want to are you done? You don't want to talk to me. He was your guest I think it's not it's not spelt to you be right It's it's spelt it's spelt if you were to say it like it's spelt sean. What would it sound like to?
You Smartless is 100 organic and artisanly handcrafted by rob armjurf benet barbaco and michael grand terry Smart less Do I have to be our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts Or you can listen to it right now early on amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to wonderie plus in apple podcasts or the wonderie app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.